Його зовнішній вигляд – це його торгова марка.
Намалюйте чоловічка, зробіть з нього Санта-Клауса,
змініть червоне пальто на чорне, приберіть капелюх
та домалюйте чорні вуса – і ось маєте Карла!
Він відомий усім, а його книги – менше.
Сьогодні справді унікальна подія в історії телебачення.
Для нас велика честь вітати в студії Карла Маркса –
засновника сучасного соціалізму
й автора маніфесту комуністичної партії.
Розвиток індустріального пролетаріату обумовлено
яким іншим розвитком?
Розвитком індустріальної буржуазії.
Його теорії сьогодні деградують до каверзних слоганів.
Він сам - майже "жарт" -
химерний і недотепний!
Карле Маркс, ваше останнє запитання:
хто виграв фінал Кубка з футболу в 1949 році?
Маркс – поп-ікона,  без нього ніяк.
От і Beatles так вважали і розмістили його зображення
на легендарній обкладинці свого альбому.
Щойно розмова заходить про повалення влади,
одразу з'являється чоловік з білою бородою.
Маркс означає повстання та недосконалість.
Поп-індустрія також це знає і заробляє багато на цьому.
Торік про життя молодого Маркса зняли художній фільм.
Карл зображений різким і палким.
Злий молодий чоловік, що полум’яно промовляє
проти зубожіння пролетаріату.
Що я повинен зробити? Замовкнути?
Дозволити цензурувати мене?
Задовольнитись лише натяками, як ви це робите?
Карл Маркс і Фрідріх Енгельс: двоє великих приятелів,
воє крутих революціонерів дев’ятнадцятого століття.
Вони непокірні будь-якій владі.
Ні, пане, варто звинувачувати існуючі виробничі умови,
а не суспільство, ви – не суспільство.
Залучити увагу, спровокувати -
таке любить і рекламна індустрія.
Фідель Кастро відвідує будинок відставних революціонерів:
вони всі колись воювали проти влади капіталізму.
Звичайно, Че Гевара і Маркс теж тут.
-Нині знову час для революції.
-Йдеться про потреби людей.
Сьогодні революціонер сам є "інструментом" капіталізму
для продажу авто.
Маркс, двохсотріччя від дня народження якого нині відзначають,
і досі живе в різних образах -
як великий хіпстер.
Без маніфесту, без теорії, але все ще з пишною шевелюрою.
Принаймні, одна річ залишається незмінною – борода.